c'est une chanson qui s'appelle un homme
heureux mais on a envie de se flinguer
quand on l'écoute comment ça se fait
c'est pas contradictoire
Williams
inutile de te demander si tu es un homme
heureux ça marche très bien ce disque
chez les en solitaire tu en as combien
oh je crois qu'on a fêté le
disque d'or à peu près la semaine
dernière ça va pas disque d'or est
toujours heureux de faire ce métier et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec cette
chanson alors au départ elle était elle
est sortie comme ça un peu pas la
sauvette enfin les sorties sur sur un
disque live qui devait être simplement
un enregistrement pour avoir dans le
répertoire un enregistrement d'un
concert au piano et il se trouvait que
j'avais une chanson je chantais déjà
depuis à peu près 6 mois
qui s'est trouvé dans l'enregistrement
ils m'ont dit on va peut-être la laisser
et on l'enregistrera plus sérieusement
studio 17 hiver bon on l'a laissé dedans
il s'est trouvé que les médias ont aimé
cette chanson et l'ont passé tel que
avec le piano et on a entendu que ça
tous l'été on a entendu pas mal quand
même on est content que tu les sentais
pour nous mais c'est un homme heureux
mais on a envie de se flinguer quand on
l'écoute comment ça se fait c'est pas
contradictoire
contradictoire et ambiguë dedans il y a
deux aspects il y a de se dire pourquoi
est-ce que c'est toujours au même que ça
arrive de CB quand on est tout seul et
puis il y a aussi cette espèce de
bonheur quand on rencontre quelqu'un de
vouloir quelque chose de vrai ou une
fois pour toute quoi donc il y a ce jeu
c'est ambiguïté en permanence dans la
chanson que j'aimais bien le bravo on
l'applaudit William Sheller
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu